Tons of couples meet at work.
It’s a safe place to get to know someone
before deciding wether or not to shave your
legs and meet them for a drink in the real
world.
Plus, job talk is guaranteed conversation
fodder, and fills those long silences nicely.
Us mortals aren’t the only ones who find
our partners this way— the stars do it too.
Here are 10 Popular Actors Who Found Love
On A Movie Set.
Ryan Gosling and Eva Mendes, The Place Beyond
the Pines
In 2012’s The Place Beyond The Pines, the
chemistry between Ryan Gosling and Eva Mendes
is so intense, it’ll steam up the inside
of your screen.
Director Derek Cianfrance tells the gritty
story of a man dead set on providing for his
family.
After learning about the birth of his son,
Gosling’s character quits the carnival and
gets himself a real profession: bank robber.
It was on this movie that Mendes and Gosling
met, and they’ve been an item ever since.
They’re married, and even have a couple
of kids.
Andrew Garfield and Emma Stone, The Amazing
Spider-Man
When Andrew Garfield described meeting Emma
Stone for the first time in 2011, he said
it was “like diving into whitewater rapids
and having no desire to hang on to the side”.
The two began dating while working on The
Amazing Spider-Man, and stayed together for
four years afterward.
It’s a good thing the two liked each other,
since the movie had a pretty intense promotional
schedule that saw them spending every single
day in close proximity for months.
And even though they broke up in 2015, the
pair are still great friends.
Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively, Green Lantern
Opening to largely negative reviews, 2011’s
Green Lantern was panned by audiences for
its overuse and reliance on CGI.
Especially when it came to the main character’s
suit.
And although it’s viewed as an all-around
disappointment, one good thing did come from
the movie: the real life romance of Blake
Lively and Ryan Reynolds.
Yes, there was some time in between those
two events, but it’s the end result we care
about.
Both on screen and off, the two make a fantastic
team, and celebrated the arrival of their
first child in 2014.
Tom Cruise and Nicole Kidman, Days of Thunder
Tom Cruise may be known for his couch-jumping,
Oprah stunt where the actor proclaimed his
love for actress Katie Holmes.
But back before Dawson’s Creek was invented,the
actor set his sights on another willowy lady
— Nicole Kidman.
The two met while filming the stock car racing
flick Days of Thunder.
The two fell head over heels and got married
that same year.
And remained a couple until 2001, even starring
in a few movies together during their relationship.
Since the two went their separate ways, Cruise
has been on a series of high profile love-quests,
but nothing as enduring as his connection
to Kidman.
Channing Tatum and Jenna Dewan, Step Up
Before he was workin’ the pole as Magic
Mike, Channing Tatum was hot stepping all
over one lady’s heart on the set of 2006’s
Step Up.
His character Tyler ends up at a performing
arts school after a series of poor decisions.
Spoiler alert: Tyler’s checkered past countered
by his passion for dance turns out to be a
catalyst for change.
And he falls in love with a fellow student
named Nora.
Life imitates art, and the two young students
fell head over heels for each other in real
life too.
The couple has been together ever since, and
no discussion about relationship goals is
complete without at least a few nods in their
direction.
Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie, Mr. and Mrs.
Smith
Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie met on the set
of Mr. and Mrs. Smith in 2005, and began the
process of falling in love.
The only thing is that Brad wasn’t technically
single at the time, and Jennifer Aniston fans
were PISSED.
Rumors of his infidelity swirled like tumbleweeds
in a tornado, and everyone and their dog was
picking a side.
But once Pitt and Jolie were “official”,
Brangelina became a grade-A Hollywood power
couple with a humanitarian focus.
They have six children and got married in
2014.
And their recent split made the 6 o’clock
news everywhere.
Gwyneth Paltrow/Brad Pitt, Se7en
Brad, Brad, Brad.
We meet again.
In addition to Angelina and Jen, the actor
also had a high-profile relationship with
actress Gwyneth Paltrow in the mid-nineties.
And at one point they even had matching haircuts.
The two actors met on the set of Se7en, and
if you’ve seen the movie, you’ll know
its story is a morbid one.
So the fact that these two somehow found the
energy to flirt after long days of dealing
with a deranged murderer is amazing.
They were engaged to be married, but the blonde
babes ultimately split after three years together.
Helena Bonham Carter/Tim Burton, Planet of
the Apes
Ever notice how many of Tim Burton’s movies
feature Helena Bonham Carter?
Since 2001, the actress has been a fixture
in the director’s work.
After meeting on Burton’s Planet of the
Apes, the two creative types began a relationship
onscreen and off.
Their chemistry is undeniable, and the actress
is the perfect fit for Burtons cinematic sensibilities.
If it’s in the best interest of the character,
she’s not afraid to get weird.
But after eight movies, two kids, and thirteen
years, the couple went their separate ways.
Milla Jovovich/Paul W.S. Anderson, Resident
Evil
Love ‘em or hate ‘em, there are six installments
in the Resident Evil movie franchise.
And Paul W.S. Anderson was involved with every
single one of them.
He owes a lot to the series, including his
marriage to wife Milla Jovovich.
They met on the set of the first chapter and
have been together ever since.
It’s probably really awesome to see your
wife play one of the most badass female characters
to ever hit the big screen.
The actress has a habit of playing strong
ladies, and Alice is one of the best.
Margot Robbie/Tom Ackerley, Suite Française
Sorry to shatter the illusion everyone, but
Margot Robbie is one very taken lady.
We know, it hurts.
But they are the cutest couple on the planet,
so turn that frown upside down.
While filming Suite Francaise, one of the
assistant directors caught the actress’
eye.
Apparently Robbie and husband Tom Ackerley
hit it off instantly and the rest, as they
say, is history.
The two initially kept their relationship
on the DL, but the cat’s out of the bag
now and there’s no going back.
The couple got married on the beach back in
2016.
Those are our picks for actors who fell in
love on their movie sets, but if you can think
of any others, let us know about them in the
comments.
And head over to our YouTube channel to see
more of our stuff.
Thanks for watching.